every day organizations with processes
that rely on documents are wasting time
and money when they don't have to thanks
to new developments in mobile document
capture the days of sending documents to
some faraway image processing center are
fading along with a cost and delays of
document shipping today documents don't
even need to be sent to a nearby branch
office or to any scanner at all with IBM
data cap mobile document capture it's
quick and easy to capture data from
documents and other sources wherever and
whenever they're created that makes life
better for your customers your employees
and your business IBM data cap mobile
document capture can create a true
competitive advantage for business like
a bank that adds it to a check scanning
application an insurance company that
offers it to people by new policies or
updating existing coverage or any
customer oriented organization that
wants to create a better customer
experience IBM data cap mobile document
capture is part of a complete set of
solutions for enterprise content
management from IBM